welcome back to new rockstars with so
much marvel content coming down the
pipeline this year in the form of movies
and streaming series we're beginning to
wonder if any of these heroes are going
to ever team up again and you know
avenge the planet and whatnot it's kind
of their thing it's their job assemble
already jesus christ it's only been a
couple of seconds since an endgame we
want to see you guys together again this
is rogue theory the show where we pitch
the wildest theories for the nerdy
titles that we love my name is mt and
growing world with me today is someone
who always calls shotgun in the quinjet
it's jessica clements what's going on
jessica hi
happy st patrick's day today but not in
the future oh happy saint patty's day
everybody oh you you're in your green i
see your green on yeah
i love every holiday except for columbus
day i love every holiday
i love every holiday except for columbus
columbus all day i mean someone who
always plays well with others it's
whitney van laninger hi i play well with
all others except for christopher
columbus exactly christopher columbus
did not play well with others at all
that's what we learned today
um and our very own iron man who's
always ready to bring the party to you
it's tommy bechtel what's going on
brother
chris columbus the director of home
alone okay christopher columbus yeah the
conquistador racist no way no
the best you could do is just be like
call me chris because they're going to
get mad at me if they hear my phone call
me they're getting so mad at me we're
recording on st patrick's day and i've
had a couple whiskeys
in the holiday spirit i dig it it is the
thirsty thursday of all thirsty
thursdays oh man that's true
some might say it is the thirstiest
thursday the thirsty is thursday my
nickname
it's thursday it's thursday
you're in the addams family right
there's pugsley wednesday it's your
sister
thursday's thursday
i just crawl on the ground hung over and
said
yeah i'm so horny
and hungover i i editorialized my own
feelings
oh my goodness all right guys so during
an interview this week benedict
cumberbatch explained how he saw doctor
strange not as an avenger but rather as
a slight outsider as an avenger so
because he sees the character as
protecting the reality of the avengers
rather than you know someone who is
taking orders from nick fury so that
leads us to our first topic today that's
such a doctor strange answer like he is
such a stranger
he had the he had the cape on and
everything and he said no
no i'm not an avenger i'm if i have to
answer to somebody that means i'm not in
charge so
i don't really like that i'm protecting
the very reality of the thing you're
asking if i am no i am so above this
yeah
i'm
avenging on a different level than you
guys i'm literally protecting your
reality okay
i'm going to say right now horrible
horrible question
we're already mad about this question
because you've already brought the anger
in us but keep going
but that leads us to our first topic
today who even are the avengers like
what is the makeup of the avengers team
right now and why do we not know the
answer at this point like who is even of
an avenger right now like is there
anything going on behind the scenes like
are the offenders even necessary it's
the most logical
answer rhodey rhodes is the leader now
because
tony is dead rhodey was his closest
confidant he showed up in falcon and
winter soldier to oversee the shield
being passed along or whatever like he
was kind of like it makes sense for
rhodey to be kind of the new iron man
in terms of leadership
i interesting i think that makes
complete sense um this is for like
unofficial records clearly because we
don't i don't think we're gonna know
until nick fury shows his face again of
course but i think they're gonna try
giving it to monica
uh i think they're gonna try giving her
the title because i think captain marvel
is going to be the like confidante or
the
man i don't know manager you want to
call it uh head head person in charge of
young avengers i think nick fury's going
to be like you go help the young
avengers while monica is going to become
somehow like the leader for
the avengers because she already has
that background as a leader and has
already and she takes charge every time
we like see her in a scene so i think
this would be a good opportunity for her
to like
throw herself in there and be like i am
going to help you guys figure out what
we should do and in what capacity i love
that
that's what i think but let's like list
off the living avengers right now of the
original team because we have four who's
still alive who's off you know with uh
one eyeball yeah i think he's back i
think he'll come back senior member of
the avengers i think thor will answer
the call
if you say thor
yeah thor yeah so i can't hear this
volume is so low on everyone but whitney
oh i'm so sorry whitney's perfect volume
everybody else
i thought we were going to be like
whitney's so [ __ ] goddamn loud
without me i'm right loud
it's good now i think it's just empty so
i'm like leaning into my microphone to
hear you better i don't know i'll fix my
microphone that's how microphones work
jess yeah
i think thor is going to be a a through
line for the avengers i think thor will
always answer the call and i think that
because chris hemsworth loves playing
thor yeah that's awesome i believe he's
not going to leave the franchise he kind
of just is thor at this point
he just lives like i love how he just
he's put so much of his own personality
in his own humor
character you don't think yeah that's
just chris hemsworth jane is gonna
come play a part in it after love and
thunder
no i think that's gonna be a closed loop
in that movie i think by the end of thor
love and thunder chris hemsworth will be
thor again whether we want that to be
the reality or not i i
think that's my prediction what about
anyone from the guardians
rocket is the head avenger now
and he's gonna steal your prosthetic leg
what if we had what if the head of the
avengers was stealing people's glass
eyes right and left uh
what if he short-circuited rody's like
walking device so then rodeo was
paralyzed like he was like he just oh my
god rock and roll
that's why rocket's not the leader
rocket would take anything if he wants
it like it doesn't matter if roadie
needs it to walk rocket will take it um
that's the quality of the leader that
you need i think he's the only one from
the guardians i could see being an
avenger because i think uh chris pratt
and james gonna kind of confirm peter
quill wants to be off earth as much as
possible oh
chris yeah is too much of a republican
to be an avenger
he can't you don't need to be vaccinated
in space guys you don't need it yeah
exactly that's why he can't come back to
the avengers because you won't get
[ __ ] vaccinated and avengers towers
checks that [ __ ]
they require a negative test to enter
you just need 70s and 80s pop music
that's all
that cures everything
i think aha cures everything you heard
it here first uh everything i think that
they should just let paul rudd be in
charge of the avengers because he's so
handsome
he's the handsomest living avenger he's
just like a stupid dummy though
i know he's a big dummy that's why they
should let him lead it should be paul
rudd and rocket raccoon
oh god
that's who i want to see together
okay let's let's let's okay let's let's
write it back into the original avengers
first
no that's okay i love this conversation
um because okay we have thor like we
said we have hawkeye we have bruce
banner the incredible guy who is going
to be a period don't think hawkeye's
coming back but keep going and we have
steve rogers who is sort of m.i.a on the
movie all right he's going supposedly
who really
i don't i never trust an off-screen
death but i'm also like it's been so
long
he's just dead now i think he's just
dead he's god i think he just died
you know medicaid is like really bad and
i don't think that he was getting the
care he needed in whatever
south florida living home he got moved
into so
treat your elders better you guys
they deserve better
it's so true but like
let's let's go back to the newest miss
marvel trailer that we just got because
in that trailer we do see that of this
bully girl zoe who doesn't even know
what she's talking about because that
avengers shirt is awesome it's a good
shirt i want one avengers shirt exactly
i love that shirt we do see on a shirt
that valkyrie and the wasp are on her
avengers shirt so
are they technically fully avengers now
like since an end game
oh yeah that's why i thought valkyrie
would be and thor would hand it to her
and then go off and do his own thing i
thought
i thought it was more than just
asgard i think she was going to be the
new replacement for
thor in there and thor would hang out
and do whatever the hell he wants to do
and sometimes show up but i thought
valkyrie would take that spot
i'm into that because we deserve a
bisexual head of the avengers finally
yeah that's what i'm saying
yeah exactly that's why i pick valkyrie
they're the head of the avengers must be
bi that is exactly
what happened that is the
minimum requirement i don't think wasp
is sorry oh you don't think wasp is an
event i don't think wasp is an avenger
first before before or with ant-man i
think it would be ant-man or no like
after the events yeah
and we've already established the whole
vaccine card to get into avengers tower
thing so it's like
janet and pim are back so she's
definitely working closer with her
family whereas ant-man would work with
that's that's why she doesn't trust the
vaccine because she works at femtech and
she's like i've seen what my dad can put
into your body i know that we can get if
i can get like a microchip into that we
can get microchips everywhere
i saw darren crass working on the
microchip to put in the backseat yeah i
saw derrick crass guys he put [ __ ] in
the vaccine we're all going to become
wasps now oh my god oh geez
i would love to be a wasp yeah like i'm
cool with that if i get super powers i'm
here for it like corey stahl i'm in
absolutely
track me baby watch what i'm up to
you'll be scratched yeah you're joking
follow me
you just might like it
smash that subscribe button in the
vaccine you put in my arms
that's what i tell every nurse when
every time i get a shot i go smash that
like and follow and they're like sure
this is the cbs like this is a cvs so
you've got to smash that syringe
but no another thing that we should
probably consider are these sokovia
accords and like so i think who is
technically avenge an avenger after
the civil war that was a huge deal and
so we know especially with the way that
no way home ended and like no way home
establishing that like peter parker
spider-man is a you know a wanted
criminal pretty much does this affect
spider-man's standing as an avenger like
is he technical nobody knows who he is
right it's true so how he be avenger if
he doesn't have
he they don't know who he is right so
like but they know that spider-man
exists they just don't know who peter
parker is they know that spider-man
exists but if he doesn't know any of the
other ones how would he have gotten into
the event i don't know right i don't
think he's gonna join the avengers
anytime soon because yeah he's still
taking his ged you guys you need to
study right now
he's focusing on school he's rebuilding
the the lego death star from the
palpatine up
just let him do it
to me i feel like the sokovia accords
kind of lost
their clout after the final end game
battle i don't understand
that to me it was like
in terms even if the government was
trying to still enforce like you know uh
hawkeye and scott lang as like
uh wanted fugitives or whatever it was
like
the world sees them as saviors like they
stopped then like i don't yeah i think
they're kind of null i think sokovia
accords kind of null and void after that
final battle
except for wanda i think that wanda's
the only person that like collectively
the world is like no she still has to
follow the system
they were about her and they will stay
about her yeah yeah let's just rename
these the wando the
she can hang out in her orchard we're
not
but no like i i think in a recent
interview they did say that the sokovia
accords were still in effect though i'm
sure they're
still in effect like how you're not
supposed to jaywalk but people still do
it right um not to compare a million
people's dying to well a lot of people
die jaywalking so i think
yeah
look both ways look both ways honk your
horn so i think but i do think like
they're just not gonna acknowledge it
especially because the main person
acknowledging it was tony stark and he
is gone so i think they're just like
we're gonna still save the world saving
the world comes first because also keep
in mind all these avengers are basically
gone and the ones that are alive are the
ones that were against it so it's like
no one's gonna really care like no one's
gonna
i think that we could like really easily
solve the sokovia accords if we get
nicholas cage to just steal them
like they're the declaration of
independence we just tell
we just tell nick cage i'm going to
steal the sokovia accords yo quantum
media let's get nick cage heisting and
clutch
just because you steal the form doesn't
mean it doesn't exist in a cage we just
tell him like hey dude there's a map on
the back go and just watch him fly
i like the idea that the accords are
written on like old parchment like
they're like thunderbolt ross was like
i'm gonna write this on 200 year old
paper with a skin quill
ooh with a peter twist oh
but also another thing that we should
probably talk about is the shang qi
post-credits scene with um you know wang
coordinating with the hulk and captain
marvel and this weird little
teleconference thing situation so like
is how does wong fit on the avengers
team like is he sort of heading things
because he sort of felt like he was in
charge of the meeting why is the most
responsible person in that meeting
yeah i don't think he's in charge of the
team for setting it up i think he's the
one that got alerted and then called
upon the other people so i think he's
not like a messenger but he was the only
person that could get in contact with
everyone at once um because
doctor strange wasn't uh but doctor
strange was like i would never but i
don't i kind of okay
i guess hot take i kind of agree with
what dr strange said in his god damn
benedict cumberbatch said in their
interview where they're like i'm not
really part of the avengers i'm on the
side like i'm doing my own thing because
i'm like yeah you are kind of just in
the sanctum and you guys are working and
there's a bun like you're basically a
school you just show up when needed kind
of like how thor did at the beginning of
the avenger movies how he's like okay
i'm gonna show up to fight and i'm gonna
go back to asgard peace out
so i think that's the same way wong is
gonna be where it's like we will call
upon them when it's like an emergency
but otherwise i'm not gonna show up just
for like a random fight in new york uh
or well i guess it's in his hometown but
like if it was in san francisco he's not
just gonna just show up he's not doing a
four or five hours yeah he's not yet
he's not he's not getting on a
cross-country five-hour i'm not flying
jet blue to san francisco
yeah with the
little layover
in ohio
and anyways he's avoiding it because
that's that's where eric voss lives
anyways so you know he's not he's not
going through here
atlanta is not a layover from new york
if you're going across the country
atlanta is backward it's a slingshot and
we gotta talk to the airlines about it
they gotta stop going new york to
atlanta
they got us
i was gonna say i essentially don't so
encompassing everything i don't think
wong and cumberbatch will be but shang
chi will um because they're gonna use
that as their placement they're going to
be like use this boy he's a fighter he
can fight you guys got it
so is aquafina an avenger does that mean
it's awkward
i had i was like
i mean technically she did hit the uh
the dweller in darkness right in the
jugular when she needed to i think
hawkeye is our archer for right now and
then kate bishop will be our archer for
young avengers uh i think it would be
fun though to have that appearance with
aquafina's character uh kate kate kate
wright
yeah yeah katie i think it would be nice
for katie to either meet kate bishop or
to meet hawkeye and be like i also shoot
like i learned two like i also partake
in the uh i also shoot
but then that's just too many kates and
katie's running around with arrows and
then they're both nicely shoot what i'm
going to choose steinfeld every time man
exactly exactly we know empty shoes and
haley
and i thought my name was thirsty
thursday
and i thought that was my title the t
stands for something guys it's gonna be
thirsty
master thirsty
um but one last thing that we should
probably
transition on over to other than my love
of haley seinfeld um
one last thing is val i mean what she
was doing at the end of [ __ ] the
winter soldier because like what is
going on with this dark avengers
situation with um crazy guy um
johnny mayonnaise i don't know i call
him johnny manning
john
walker johnny isn't his name literally
like u.s agent yeah as usual us agents
yes no his name is johnny mayonnaise and
that's canon
that's true that is definitely true i'm
never calling him anything else
you just made me like yes like
appreciate that character more now i'm
like you're welcome okay crazy ass
johnny
we love you johnny mayonnaise wherever
you are
shout out to shawnee mayonnaise
poor wyatt russell's like i just wanted
to be in a marvel thing he was yeah i
just wanted to be in a marvel and now
these kids on the internet are calling
me johnny mayonnaise and i don't know
he's so punchable oh god the actor
spectacular like i love that actor so
much killed it was great about john
walker he did kill it he was so smart me
i i wanted to punch him the whole
whole time right he played it so well he
played it so well
what so is he technically an avenger now
because like we know from civil war that
the sokovia accords are like being run
by the government and all these
organizations and like captain america
even says that agendas change so like
could val be
the agenda changing and like her
introducing her new her own avengers i
agree with you completely but i also
think
it's one of those stupid like quotes of
like
avengers isn't what it is it's what's in
the heart or something like that like i
feel like nick fury's gonna say some
[ __ ] like that and nick fury's gonna sum
up like that's what the america like
that's what the world thinks our
avengers are but we're really the
avengers here like just because i'm not
in a position of power that's like in
the point like in the view of everyone
we're still doing our stuff down here so
i think we're gonna oh that's a great i
love that comment empty because it's
like i think they're gonna set him up to
think he's the hero and be the hero that
like we're gonna see him as but in
reality he's never gonna be invited to
[ __ ] and he's not actually an adventure
he's like guys are you meeting without
me again and ant-man's like no
no no no no no no it's it's weird cause
he is set up to be that way at the end
it's just like you think you're doing
good but you're doing more harm than
you're doing good so he's gonna do more
harm when he's not being invited he's
basically princess and the powerpuff
girls the avengers are the powerpuff
girls and princess is princess and she's
jealous that she's not invited to be a
powerpuff girl so she's gonna start a
fight
an original
avenger that would be very fun yeah it'd
be super dope and like i wonder
if like what they're doing with
taskmaster because we know that
taskmaster gets picked up at the end of
black widow by uh thunderbolt ross rest
in peace to an amazing guy
oh boy
i think she's just gonna go into the
shadow yeah i don't know whoever really
cares
i think there'll be a lot i don't think
there's going to be a ton of black widow
carry i think the establishment of elena
is going to be the one thing from that
movie that lives on and i have just the
way disney did it kind of dirty
like i just don't know that they're
going to put a ton of uh
backing into the other characters in
that you know like i think
i think it was a it was a it was a
vessel to introduce
yelina into the to the mcu and basically
i i wouldn't be surprised if most of the
rest of it is just kind of buried
yeah
what a shame
what a [ __ ] chain
not saying that's right just being real
it's yeah just just keeping it real just
keeping it realistic because like you
know a lot of people especially with
like you know the taskmaster and like
the reception of taskmaster wasn't 100
um
well received even though like she did a
great job they actually did a great job
as taskmaster just like we haven't seen
enough of task masterage to actually
really fall in love with taskmaster yet
unless you read the comics and you're
like this [ __ ] monster this
taskmaster is a [ __ ] badass the bee's
knees
the taskmaster is the coolest thing in
the world cool thing
yo comic book taskmaster is the best
that's the only reason i want to see it
again but i could see what tommy's what
tommy said of them just yeah i mean i
have no problem with that character
coming back i just don't i have no faith
in in disney slash
yeah same do that character justice i
guess is what i'm saying not to be a
buzzkill guy sorry not on st patrick's
day wow you sound a lot like tommy
mayonnaise now
i think it'd be a really cool scenario
where um you know in multiverse of
madness wouldn't it be cool if they
introduced comic book taskmaster into
the mcu to fight
the new taskmaster i think it'd be dope
it'll just be really cool to have two
gas masters that's me eating it yep
[Music]
i'm full
that was delicious of course i would i
would ride for that i would i would rob
a bank for that uh i would kill for that
it would be
too good what would they do mimic each
other to death
oh exactly they wouldn't be so cool just
like they have all this knowledge of
different likes
it would be so cool it's like i'm gonna
use your black panther my black panther
against your uh black widow and see what
happens oh i guess yeah if they did come
out of a different universe they would
see different superheroes so they would
be mimicking the superheroes that they
saw so we could get different
we can get like different like
references to heroes that haven't even
appeared in the mcu yet which would be
super dope we are so far off of what the
original question was i'm sorry okay
this episode of rogue theory is gonna be
nine hours long we're talking about two
taskers fighting each other the question
was what are the avengers currently or
who are they
what are the avengers two taskmasters
fighting at the same time not to be the
principal
i
i just looked at the recording i'm like
we're 30 minutes in on this and now i
know what are the multiverse of madness
taskmaster fights
[Laughter]
well if somebody's
not to be sam patrick's day every day of
the week uh these were all really great
ideas so like let's just get like a just
final count of who the avengers could be
now
geez you said 9 000
yeah let's just recap that real quick
you guys
you guys i don't know
entertain the idea
two taskmasters
uh spiderman but not peter parker
john walker
alligator captain america
captain
agent u.s agent john walker elena
people just get in the comments with
what they think the new adventure
what do you think yes that's what would
do that like who do you guys think are
in the avengers now because we don't
know but we're just we're just broke
furion over here so let us know
we clearly have no idea
yeah we don't know you guys tell us yeah
you guys are you tell us
i mean kevin feige does text me from
time to time but he hasn't texted me
this yet just kidding that's not true
but up next we're going to talk about
the cool
teenage version of the avengers next but
first
what shut up don't listen to him don't
listen
what does he text you he hits him
yeah he hits my beeper with uh smiley
faces
very nice man and hey our batman
inspired latest obsession shirt gotham
noir is almost sold out so you should
probably grab one quick over at new
rockstarsmerch.com it's a really cool
design like all of our merch our friends
over at epic hero shop are pumping out
you can only get it at
newrockstarsmerge.com and we want to
thank shutter for sponsoring this video
because when we're in the mood for a
thriller or something supernatural we
hear a new rock star's turn to shudder
where every week they premiere a new
horror movie or series which shutter you
can stream supernatural thriller in
horror movies and tv shows across all of
your favorite devices shutter streaming
library has everything from original
movies like super host shutter streaming
library has everything from original
movies like super host the boy behind
the door and pg psycho gore man to his
series creep show by executive producer
greg nichtero of the walking dead so if
you're a fan of old classics or looking
for something new you're going to love
shutters collection from all around the
world they've got favorites like
halloween and the texas chainsaw
massacre along with must-see releases
like vhs 94 and hellbender for classic
hollywood fans they've got new for
classic hollywood fans they have a new
documentary about og frankenstein actor
boris karloff along with a collection of
his movies and trust me bride of
frankenstein still holds up to this day
it's classic so stream all this and more
from shutter's ever-growing library ad
free for just 5.99 a month shutter has
everything supernatural thriller horror
and we cannot get enough of it and
you're going to love it too and right
now you can stream your first 30 days of
shutter for free go to shutter.com and
use code rogue that's s-h-u-d-d-e-r.com
[Music]
code rogue stream free for your first 30
days by going to shutter.com code rogue
in this season upgrade your daily
routine with bespoke post and their new
seasonal lineup of must-have box of
awesome collections bespoke post
partners with small businesses and
emerging brands to bring you the most
unique goods every month and they sent
us some of the best sweaters and
cardigans that were ever worn to
mankind's history no matter what you're
into box of awesome has you covered from
winter cocktails to cozy threads and
camping gear essentials box of awesome
as collections for every part of your
life and right now they have a cool
carnivore box with specialty barbecue
spice blends that looks exciting and
take the quiz at box of awesome.com to
help them pick the right box of awesome
for you it's free to sign up and you can
skip a month or cancel anytime and each
box is valued at around 70 but you only
pay a fraction of that price and with
each box of awesome you're supporting
small businesses and get 20 off your
first monthly box when you sign up at
box of awesome.com and enter code rogue
at checkout that's box of awesome dot
com code rogue for 20 off your first box
box of awesome.com code rogue and hey
it's also discouraging if you're only
making a small dent on your multiple
credit card balances each month because
you're only paying the minimums upstart
can help you pay off your existing
credit card debt quickly and start
finally getting ahead so whether it's
paying off credit cards consolidating
high interest debt or funding personal
expenses over a million people have used
upstart to get one fixed monthly payment
with a clear payoff date so rather than
looking at your credit score alone
upstart's model considers other factors
like your income employment and other
information provided in your loan
application to find you a smarter rate
for your loan you can check out your
rate without impacting your credit score
in just five minutes for loans between
1000 to fifty thousand dollars and you
could receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
which is super fast so find out how
upstart can lower your monthly payments
today when you go to upstart.com rogue
theory that's
upstart.comrobery and do not forget to
use our url to let them know that we
sent you and loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application go to
upstart.com
rogue theory all right guys well well
since we talked about the boomer
avengers it's time to check in with gen
z to see what the next batch of heroes
are going to look like which leads us to
our second topic for today
is miss marvel the first official young
avenger because as we get closer to the
miss marvel premiere we're wondering if
she will become the first official young
avenger in the mcu lineup that kevin
feige is hasn't really
officially announced but it's sort of
coming wink wink um we don't know yet
who the main villain in the series will
be but could they be a big enough threat
to officially kick off the young
avengers do you guys think it's the
watch the villain be just like a child
or a teenager and they're like well we
can't beat him up he's a teenager so
they just make a team of young avengers
to go feed them up yeah um i think i
think um ms marvel
um or yeah i think she will be the first
official official avenger because i
think with her connections
she will be the first one that's like
knighted by nick fury
um that that's what i'm thinking because
and falcon in the winter soldier um
no one
no one officially talked to him
and then um who else who else was there
who else is the other one that we're
like thinking is gonna be another young
avenger that's showing up already okay
bishop okay bishop also hasn't gotten
the like official go ahead she's just
working with hawkeye but miss marvel has
like the connections to everyone that
are too um
um
to captain
oh god too many names too many [ __ ]
names
the connection to captain marvel that's
going to be the right who's the
right-hand man to like nick fury so i
think nick fury's gonna knight her as
the first one into league what if what
if the last episode of miss marvel we
find ourselves in a familiar donut shop
sitting down and a
in a file folder slides across the table
in the booth and says and it's you hear
a familiar voice saying we're putting
together a team
a little younger
like
together
not everyone's going to be drinking age
we're putting together a junior that's
how they say it that's how they
introduce it you have to be 19 and
younger and it's like god damn it
you have to be eligible for the hunger
games yeah are you eligible for the
hunger games they're like we get it
we're young you don't need to bring up a
bunch of young teen novels
this is the twilight of the older
avengers it's
[Laughter]
simply a hunger game now
also from the trailer
she looks like she has the most like
she's
she's i don't know i guess it's like
because we've seen more of her than the
other ones kind of in that i don't know
it's like kate bishop is kind of still
learning while she is just like this kid
isn't wasn't raised like rich and wasn't
raised like she's just like
i'm a brown girl getting super powers
and i'm working around the world and
what's happening right now and i'm still
like
she acknowledges the world around her so
i think she'd be a good leader for the
avengers because she's just like
just aware of everything
yes
i really do
like that idea i never really thought
about it but yeah yeah like it makes
sense for her to be the leader
especially with his her nick fury
connections through on miss captain
marvel but also because she's obsessed
with superheroes like she knows
a lot about the avengers and what it is
one of us what
are you saying
i am a superhero
yes i i'm saying that we could all be
young avengers if we could emphatically
are we young again
oh god
i make noises every time i stand up
seriously i complain every time i wake
up i'm just like ah existence i said i'm
older than all of you so stop
oh geez but no um i it just makes a lot
of sense because like you know if you
know for some reason i honestly do feel
like this mcu is setting up a scenario
where all the og avengers are going off
into space with whatever nick fury is
dealing with and all these new avengers
the young avengers and like all the
these new blood people um like your your
daredevils on them are going to have to
face off against something else on earth
so i think it'd be really cool for a
miss marvel to gather up all the use and
be like all right guys i know we don't
know what we're doing but i know a lot
about the avengers from my fan fiction
so i'll figure it out
dude i write fanfiction about this all
the time i got this i got a plan all
right
everyone open up your lisa frank
notebooks to page six
and we'll go over my drawings of thor
with half a mermaid body everyone please
log on to my geocities page i am not
going to lay out
my geocities has an answer for this for
this
it'll all be laid out clearly there what
they could do is if we do get an
eventual secret wars that would be the
introduction for i mean it might be
longer in the future but that would be a
good introduction to them because it's
like all our superheroes are missing
follow the like keys of uh
the event of invincible where it's like
yeah we have these older superheroes are
gonna handle the bigger [ __ ] and we need
like different other superhero groups to
handle other matters and different
factions factions so i think
that would be i think you're going into
space shooting them off and just losing
all of them we're like who's the next
ones and it's like here's a bunch of
16 year olds it's a bunch of children
curfew based heroes
curfew-based heroes
that's what we need that's why criminals
do things at night because they're
afraid of the young avengers yeah
exactly their inventors are active
during the day yeah they criminals also
are just super active between the hours
of 7am and 3pm because that's when
they're all in school they're go-getters
they're like farmers they're mourning
people they're taking care of their
families and then robbing people for
their families at night yeah their kids
are at the uh daycare they have to do
all their criminaling while their kids
are at daycare and then they have to
pick their kids at three
it's very sad um
um but yeah no it does make sense for
for miss marvel to be that leader in
that scenario um but what do you think
whitney did you go whitney uh yeah no i
do i do think that miss marvel is gonna
be uh they head up oh but
nah [ __ ] it i i think that kid loki is
the new head of the avengers
i totally forgot about kid loki for a
second there
because like he is a factor and he he is
on the young avengers don't write him
off just yet he's he's a kid and he's
tricky and he's going far what was kid
loki's uh situation it was he the one
that killed his brother but he didn't
actually do it like we know that he
killed his brother yeah from like you
know him telling the other loki's in the
void but we don't really know exactly
yeah
yeah because that means he has something
i'm just forgetting humanity so he'd be
still good with an actual avengers group
and like we do have the the bradley boy
isaiah bradley's granddad
who is going to be patriot which is
going to be very interesting to see um
so yeah i think that she would make a
great hero or a great leader for the
team though i would really love to see
kate bishop as a leader personally
because yeah obviously yeah
we get it she was there at the battle of
new york she saw hawkeye she has i'm a
little person she was basically part of
this i'm a little parched so master
first you know
respectfully i have a crush on you and
i'd like you to be the lead of the young
avengers yeah she goes uh no thanks
exactly compared to like what the rest
of her dm's are probably that would be
the nicest thing she ever heard yeah
the rest of her dm's are like i want to
wear your face as a mask
if you're going to message hayley
steinfeld you better be yourself i agree
yeah be sweet
you're gonna message any woman on the
internet be sweet seriously anybody in
general just anybody in general i'm
surprised not me though come at me with
your nasty as [ __ ] guys i invite it
dm tommy if you're nasty get real filthy
with your mask
you really you're a lonely one
but now it is time for our rogue
question you guys ready for this one
these weren't all rogue questions
now is the time to go now's the time to
get out there extra okay so now now is
when we stop taking it seriously
now we're now we're gonna get a little
bit goofy for once
because actor john hand confirmed that
he was in talks to play mr sinister in a
post-credits scene for the new mutants
that never actually came to be that
would have been amazing
that would have been really cherry on
top of that insane movie as if john him
just
sauntered in as mr sinister
but he's just doing it like
it's comforting
it reminds you
oh my god
that was a good one um we don't we
haven't actually confirmed that tommy
isn't actually john hamm in disguise yes
i'm johnny i'm wearing a mask for an
assignment for an assignment
i'm going rogue it's john hann
but no guys which comic book character
would you guys like to see jon hamm play
on from either dc or marvel or i guess
another comic book franchise that isn't
dc or marvel
a role that we that he shouldn't be
playing but
is playing anyway
um okay
any role
black panther
yeah i guess i guess i guess for me the
new the new t'challa would be the
obvious
i can't think of a single person on the
internet who would argue with that
choice it just doesn't mean it'd be
perfectly fine let's see the next one's
going on oh my god
[Applause]
it's a nation he's like i'm from south
africa
he he breaks the symbol to smack an
intern on the ass
just oh my god oh my god i don't know
how we can adopt this do we have to
actually come up with real ideas now
because that's the one
i
old bruce wayne he should be a
middle-aged bruce wayne and never be
better no then he should just go he
should just go to functions
and write checks like
he should just give big golf tournament
style checks
on screen as bruce wayne but never ever
wear the bad suit he's just always
showing up with his 35 000 that's so
funny if you just hired another actor to
play the bruce wayne persona and just
have a different batman they're like
matthew lillard plays batman in the
backseat but john hamm is bruce wayne
it's crazy yo yo honestly matthew
leather would probably go ham on batman
batman we'd see just absolutely take a
huge bite of a sandwich and spill
mustard all over
all over the shoot over the hardness
dripping in pickle juice
mustard sourdough you have [ __ ] all over
your suit oh man
my parents are gonna kill me and that's
the other thing your parents
batman's parents are alive in this
version in this version
in the matthew lillard
universe
i'm ready for the lillard first but it's
going to be big i hear it kevin feige's
talking about it
he's going to text you yeah honestly yo
this is like sort of sort of like off
topic but like
i think matthew lillard would be an
amazing michael korvac in the demar in
the marvels i think he'd be oh yeah
really good at marketing are we starting
a a petition to get matthew lillard in
the mcu today i am yeah these are great
actually it is great is this all coming
back to me and matthew lillard
co-starring in the film blood sucking
bastards in 2012
together and it has all been a meaning
that both me and matthew lillard equally
as famous need to both be in the mc
is that what this is all about i think
so this is all
the theory
okay i figure we should just wrap it up
it's time to drink some guinness guys
i've wasted an hour of my saint
patrick's day okay
but that is it for this episode of rogue
theory we're all winners today because
no one wins
absolutely zero people win this one
episode the winner is oh my goodness
chemical dependency
it will always win kids until you draw a
line it's true
jesus is crazy
yeah let's end it on that oh my god that
is it for this episode of road through
don't forget to buy our merchant epic
hero shop no i'm just going to i'm just
kidding
thank you thank you to our guest jessica
clemens whitney van lenningham and tommy
bechtold for joining us today support
them all all their stuff on social media
follow follow them all on twitter and
all that stuff and support our channel
by checking out all of our awesome merch
over at newrocksourcemerch.com and if
you've got thoughts of some of our rogue
theories you can share them over on our
discord server so if you're eight over
18 click the link in the description for
our new rockstars discord follow me on
master tammy if you want to see me tweet
some weird [ __ ] but most importantly
follow new rockstars on all our social
media platforms thank you guys so much
again for watching we love you guys and
you guys are amazing and i'll see you
guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you